buongiorno a tutti io
lavoro in un paese che non è molto
è molto conosciuto che si chiama timor
est è un paese a metà strada tra
l'australia e l'indonesia che ha avuto
25 anni una lunghissima guerra civile
con l'indonesia che ha lasciato il paese
praticamente distrutto essendo uno dei
paesi più poveri dell'asia
ci sono chiaramente tantissimi problemi
di natura economica e sociale che vanno
ancora risolti io sono arrivato a timor
est
come tutte le persone che fanno un po il
mio lavoro
un po per caso un po per scelta ma
sempre seguendo il filo logico di un
pensiero una considerazione che ha
sempre accompagnato
ci hanno la mia vita da studente che la
mia vita professionale e la curiosità è
questa noi sicuramente viviamo in un
mondo che ha un livello di sviluppo
tecnologico avanzatissimo abbiamo siamo
abbiamo raggiunto la luna 50 anni fa
riusciamo a fare delle operazioni
chirurgiche che sono sicuramente
complessissimi abbiamo un sistema di
comunicazione che è globale
per esempio io sono in skype
invidio skype con la mia bimba che ha
sei anni da timor est con i nonni qui a
trento ogni domenica una cosa che
sicuramente farà molto felice i nonni ma
che dieci anni fa era considerata
fantascienza ecco io mi sono sempre
domandato ma con tutta questa tecnologia
a disposizione dell'umanità perché un
miliardo di persone soffre ancora la 7
non ha a disposizione acqua potabile non
è forse più facile mettere acquedotti e
rubinetti in africa piuttosto che
mandare una sonda spaziale su marte
quest'oggi vi vorrei parlare con voi di
uno dei grandi problemi che tutt'oggi
affligge l'umanità e che il problema
della mortalità infantile
ogni anno nel mondo quattro milioni di
bambini muoiono per cause che sarebbero
facilmente prevenibili
prima di raggiungere i 28 giorni di età
un mese di età 4 milioni sono veramente
tanti circa 11.000 ogni giorno
ecco vorrei far vedere questa
diapositiva che rappresenta il mani e il
problema in maniera un po più precisa è
un sogno
tutti i dati della ms basati su una
ricerca dell'ente del 2005 come possiamo
vedere da quella curva che scende la
mortalità nei bambini al di sotto di 5
anni ed è cresciuta in maniera davvero
rilevante negli ultimi 50 anni
questo grazie a campagne di vaccinazione
grazie al controllo della diarrea
grazie a una maggiore igiene d'este allo
sviluppo economico delle società invece
se guardiamo a quelle barrette verticali
sul fondo del grafico rappresentano la
mortalità infantile e la parte gialla
rappresenta la mortalità infantile
precoce cioè quella nei primi sette
giorni di vita che sono i più pericolosi
e più delicati per il neonato
ecco possiamo vedere che la mortalità
nei neonati e soprattutto la mortalità
dei neonati nella prima settimana di
vita è rimasta praticamente la stessa
negli ultimi 50 anni
nonostante tutto lo sviluppo tecnologico
che abbiamo avuto nel settore della
medicina
quindi se vogliamo raggiungere gli
obiettivi del millennio nel 2015
se vogliamo veramente ridurre in maniera
ulteriore la mortalità dei bambini
dobbiamo concentrarci in quel periodo
della vita che il più pericoloso
dobbiamo partire dai primissimi istanti
di vita ma perché continuano a morire i
neonati nei paesi in via di sviluppo
beh sicuramente ci sono tantissimi
motivi per cui questo succede motivi di
ordine culturale e antropologico
economico si potrebbero scrivere 10
saggi sul problema io oggi vorrei
sottolineare con voi
uno di questi problemi che però è
importantissimo questa foto è stata
scattata nel centro del vietnam circa
cinque anni fa ma potrebbe essere stata
scattata una settimana fa in africa
oppure un mese fa nel centro america
secondo lo ms l'organizzazione mondiale
della sanità il 90 per cento dei
macchinari medici donati o acquistati
dai paesi in via di sviluppo smette di
funzionare entro un anno dal loro
acquisto
questo succede chiaramente per vari
motivi ma uno dei motivi principali è
perché nei paesi in via di sviluppo non
esiste un eco sistema di supporto
che permette a questi macchinari di
funzionare in maniera adeguata
quindi se macchinari si rompono non
esistono in loco i pezzi di ricambio se
anche i pezzi di ricambio ci fossero non
esistono degli ingegneri biomedici
adeguati che possono cambiare i pezzi e
rimettere le macchine in funzione gli
ospedali del paese in via di sviluppo
sono diversissimi degli ospedali nei
paesi occidentali sono disorganizzati
c'è molta polvere alle volte ci sono
pure degli insetti e quindi i macchinari
molto costosi ma anche molto delicati si
rovinano subito nel contesto del paese
in via di sviluppo e quindi ci troviamo
con questa situazione i macchinari in un
cortile a prendere polvere e 100 metri
più in là i neonati che muoiono nella la
pediatrica dell'ospedale
quindi che cosa fare di fronte a un
problema di queste dimensioni circa
dieci anni fa in vietnam
io stavo lavorando per la cooperazione
trentina con due organizzazioni molto
piccole ma molto dinamiche appunto del
trentino il gruppo trentino di
volontariato e gli amici della nato lo
jia trentina tra i vari progetti di cui
mi occupavo stavo anche lavorando con
l'ospedale locale del villaggio dove
vivevo una cittadina a metà strada tra
noi e la cina il l'ospedale in questione
aveva un numero di parti che era davvero
rilevante circa 15 mila nati ogni anno
per fare un confronto in trentino in un
anno nascono circa 5 mila neonati
quindi questo ospedale aveva da solo
tutti i neonati del trentino per tre
volte il 30 per cento dei neonati
ricoverati nella pediatria di questo
ospedale moriva entro una settimana di
vita non ce la faceva proprio
oppure quei pochi che avevano qualche
speranza di cavarsela venivano mandati
ad hanoi su una motoretta oppure su un
carretto insomma con mezzi di fortuna
non era ancora al tempo delle ambulanze
arrivavano chiaramente ad hanoi in
condizioni critiche la maggior parte
comunque moriva ecco nella ricerca di
una soluzione a questo problema
ho incontrato un ingegnere americano che
erano molto
sugli anni che lavorava in questo
settore in vietnam cercava in tutti i
modi di riparare le macchine mediche di
creare un database di quale macchine
esistessero i quali pezzi di ricambio
fossero necessarie disponibili e dopo un
po si era arreso all'evidenza che era
impossibile creare un sistema
artificiale che facesse funzionare
questi macchinari medici nell'ambiente
del vietnam
in quel caso e così gli era venuta
l'idea di realizzare in loco con
materiali locali e con ingegneri locali
tutte quelle tecnologie mediche
necessarie alla sopravvivenza dei
neonati a me chiaramente l'idea fin
dall'inizio mi ha affascinato e quindi
abbiamo deciso di lavorare insieme su
questo progetto
la prima cosa che ci siamo domandati è
perché muoiono esattamente i neonati
ricoverati nell'area neonatale e quello
che abbiamo scoperto è che la maggior
parte dei neonati nasceva prematuro e
quindi moriva per una problematica che è
molto comune alla maggior parte dei nati
prematuri che sono le insufficienze
respiratorie
i bambini di 25 o 30 settimane di
entrate sta triennale non hanno ancora i
polmoni che sono maturati quindi non
riescono a dare abbastanza ossigeno al
corpo e muoiono dopo vari giorni
così di lavoro per cercare di avere
abbastanza ossigeno nei tessuti
ora quindi con questo ingegnere
americano avevamo deciso di provare a
costruire un qualcosa che fosse adatto
ai paesi in via di sviluppo e quindi
abbiamo creato una macchina si pappa
fatta in loco fatta da ingegneri
vietnamiti perché potesse essere adatta
ai paesi in via di sviluppo e quindi la
macchina non è costruita secondo il
principio di come l'ospedale dovrebbe
essere o come l'ospedale ci piacerebbe
che fosse è costruita secondo il modo in
cui l'ospedale purtroppo è e quindi ecco
che per esempio visto che l'elettricità
assolutamente instabile nei paesi in via
di sviluppo
la macchina a uno stabilizzatore interno
che stabilizza l'elettricità e la
protegge visto che dottori non sono
molto esperti nella terapia respiratoria
la macchina
semplicissima ha solamente tre funzioni
e 5 bottoni non uno di più per poter
essere usata in tutti i contesti
possibili
la macchina è completamente sigillata
non ci sono né non ci sono nessun buco
diciamo pure porta usb che permetta la
polvere o all umidità di entrare e di
distruggerla
ma soprattutto tutti i circuiti della
sipap sono completamente lavabili non
possono essere lavati asciugati
sterilizzati e poi utilizzati per il
prossimo paziente in modo che la possano
usare per anni e anni dopo che essa è
stata donata e così siamo riusciti a
fare una macchina che funziona
praticamente in ogni ambiente ed è in
grado di salvare appunto la vita a quei
neonati che altrimenti sarebbero morti
di distress respiratorio
all'inizio abbiamo chiaramente fatto un
progetto pilota in un ospedale specifico
del vietnam e c'era bisogno di un
sostegno di un aiuto a realizzare tutta
la parte clinica medica tutti i
protocolli di uso quando utilizzarla
quando smetterla quali bambini scegliere
beh questo è stato realizzato tutto da
medici volontari trentini del santa
chiara di trento oppure della rete
ospedaliera trentina in un progetto di
sviluppo finanziato dalla provincia di
trento
il progetto ha avuto un successo davvero
strepitoso un'ampia riduzione della
mortalità infantile nella prima
settimana di vita una riduzione dei
trasferimenti ad hanoi una riduzione
della metà del tempo di trattamento dei
neonati e quindi ci siamo incoraggiati
da questi risultati abbiamo fatto il
prossimo ospedale poi quello dopo e poi
quello dopo
fino a che la fondazione di miss west
che è una fondazione e basata in
california che una delle più grandi
agenzie di sviluppo presente nel sud est
asiatico annotato le potenzialità di
questo modello e ha deciso di creare un
programma che si chiama brecht of life
soffio di vita e che intende sostenere
questo modello di sviluppo per tutti gli
ospedali del sud est asiatico e adesso
anche dell'africa io non ho molto tempo
disposizione quindi vorrei fare una
storia di dieci anni molto breve
abbiamo già distribuito quasi mille
macchinari in 300 ospedali del sud est
asiatico e dell'africa
e anche del sud asia come l'india
pensate che ci sono 50 mila neonati ogni
anno che sono al giorno d'oggi in
trattamento con le tecnologie donate
procurate dal nostro programma
ecco in conclusione io vorrei tornare
quello che diceva un po l'inizio alla
domanda che mi facevo silenzio dei miei
studi nel mio lavoro ma è mai possibile
che con tutta questa tecnologia a
disposizione del mondo un miliardo di
persone soffre ancora la sete
devo essere sincero e non ne ho la più
pallida idea io so però che con un
design che sia innovativo con un design
che guardi ai bisogni concreti e reali
di chi utilizza le tecnologie e non di
chi le produce e con una logica che non
guardi al profitto ma che guardi ai
risultati che si ottengono nella pratica
medica come in altri campi del
dell'attività umana è possibile
raggiungere un modello di sviluppo
tecnologico che sia appropriato prima di
tutto ma poi che sia anche efficace per
i risultati che ottiene è che sia
soprattutto sostenibile nel tempo
e questo il programma presto online e
grazie a tutti per l'attenzione